hey everyone this is stephen weintraub
with collider and i am thrilled to be
with this all-star group to talk about
moving on at the toronto international
film festival gentlemen i really want to
start with i'm a fan of all of your work
thank you so much for coming in i really
appreciate it thank you so much for
having us thanks um i love throwing a
curveball or two at the beginning before
we get into the movie but all three of
you have illustrious resumes if someone
has actually never seen anything you've
done before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why
well this film
but no joke i think that sort of uh you
know it's one wonderful thing about
working with actors who've done so many
great performances over decades is that
you can kind of see glimpses of the
great performances in a current
performance if they challenge themselves
and if it's the kind of beautiful work
that malcolm and and richard did
obviously this film as well
and um i'd have to go back
for a film um once upon a time when we
were colored
and the reason being
that was the first time my dad had ever
acknowledged what i do
my dad was a very religious man he
didn't go to movies he didn't drink he
didn't smoke and
he didn't come to the premiere of the
movie
and he was out visiting me in california
and we were sitting out on the on the in
the living room and i said dad sit down
i want you to see something
and he sat there
the entire time
and saw this movie and without looking
at me
you said
well done
so that
is very special to me
that's a beautiful story
that is
my father only saw me once in a movie
and unfortunately not quite as
nice of a story in that the movie was
caligula
[Laughter]
my father uh came to stay with me in
rome and um
kept asking when can i come to the set
you know and i mean you know dad i don't
tomorrow's not a good day you know we've
we're on location we're lying and you
know tap dancing
went on for a week or more and
i came down at six o'clock for the
driver and my father's already in the
car
and i thought oh god what am i shooting
oh god i've got a piss
on
camera or on against a
a marble pillar in the middle of a
speech oh jesus
i thought oh well you know anyway i get
to the thing we rehearse it i'm applying
me with coffee the director goes are you
ready no one more coffee
i take my coffee i go up and i win
i am rome wherever i am how'd it come
pissing against the thing wherever i am
rome is oh god
and
then two
servants come and clean it up as they
would in caligula's time
and i and i'd forgotten of course my
father was there and when they said cut
i looked around started my father who
had a cane you know he had a bit of a
gimpy leg
jumped up and he went
that was fantastic
i've never seen acting like that he goes
you pissed like that thank you
that's also a great thank you for
sharing that that's great um i'm so
curious for the two of you because you
um have been in the industry for so long
when did you feel as that you could make
a living and pay your rent as an actor
after the
[Music]
premiere of shaft
that's when i
i'm
really going back now i remember
my grandmother who lived to be 103 years
old
i took her to see a play i was doing way
off broadway canal street
that's way off broadway yeah and uh
if it was 25 people in there was
standing room only
and
miss lucy is is sitting
in front of the stage
and watching this play go on and i'm
standing in the wings watching her
after the play was over i went over
and i said miss lucy uh what did uh what
did you think of the play
and she looked at me
boy is that the way you're gonna make a
living
yes
but that was that was the start for me
when i felt
comfortable on stage
and
then we had the the chef uh premiere and
i said uh
this might go somewhere
well i i was um
started out you know
a 20 year old actor um
in weekly rep
that's one play a week at the summer
season
and i was play paid i think eight pounds
a week
which would i probably be today maybe
fifty dollars a week or something
um
and i thought you know i died and gone
to heaven
you know it it's all um
you know it's all a matter of where you
are in your life i was just as happy
on that as i am getting big great big
sums because um
it's a matter of uh where you're at
artistically being free and having fun i
think
so it in terms of
money
don't ever be an actor if you want to be
rich hello or famous forget it
uh if you want to be a
a good professional that's something
else you can work
on really hard and and that's it and you
know
i started off my life in london in
england
and uh there the tradition is the
theater there's no film business or
there wasn't in those days and if you
got a film it was like a golden nugget
who pay your rent for the year
and it was like we all wanted to do a
movie
and um
you know i was very very lucky to be
cast in a movie called if which became
a
huge core celeb movie you know it was a
revolutionary movie about a revolution
in a boys school and um
in particular a public school which in
england is like a private school in
america
and it's where the um aristocrats sent
their sons to be educated to go out and
rule the empire so-called
and uh you know i met this great
director lindsay anderson and we became
friends for the next 30 years until he
sadly died
and so um i didn't really make any money
until my second movie the first one
i i would have paid them i actually got
paid 90 pounds a week
and that soon gone and i had to wait a
year for the damn thing to open
because in those times editing
and scoring it and doing all that they
took forever
and then the movie won the grand prize
at the cannes film festival and that was
it kiss my ass
[Laughter]
kubrick saw it cast me i didn't
and that's the last time i think
i auditioned
uh thank you for sharing this story um
uh paul i have a question for you you've
made a number of movies um which of the
films that you have made changed the
most in the editing room in ways you did
not expect
um actually about a boy
we
um
we had
damon goff who's
stage name is badly drawn boy do uh the
music for it because chris and i my
brother i did that with my brother that
which was a lovely thing to do is to
direct films with your brother assuming
you get along which we we do um
and uh when we were writing the script
for that we were listening to his music
all the time and we said well what if we
get him to do the music for the movie um
and so we really eventually edited a lot
of it to the music because we knew ahead
of time what songs we were going to have
and
um uh
and then so there were a lot of kind of
surprises and um
some arguments between chris and i over
what was gonna work or not and uh
um we uh so yeah i think i think that
one changed the most actually
jumping into why i get to talk to you
guys today and i appreciate your
indulgence in my early questions um talk
a little bit about the genesis of the
project um actually what does it mean to
all three of you to be in the toronto
international film festival with the
movie because this is my favorite
festival and
everyone here just loves cinema and i'm
just curious what it means to all of you
um it's great for me the the first movie
that i had my name on was an animated
movie called ants
which had uh
woody allen meryl streep sylvester
stallone was one of the first big sort
of uh new generation of animated movies
so everybody thought oh this is my
chance to be in an animated movie so
everyone everyone they asked said yes
and gene hackman was in it
and
so but but anyway that that movie uh
premiered here at toronto and i haven't
been here
for the festival since then um
uh and uh so it's
it's really lovely and i'm i'm very
excited to have this very
um uh homemade movie um uh be premiering
in front of 2600 people on tuesday um
that should be an interesting experience
um and
uh it's it's you know it's lovely to all
be here the the um yeah so
well this is the first time uh
being at the toronto film festival i've
only attended one other film festival
khan film festival
for with a film that no one has ever
seen
but this one i am equally
excited about
being
in this film with this role with this
cast and it has been a joy ride
to say the least
the last time i was here was with robert
altman
who of course
and
just needs no uh explaining and
he was an extraordinary man a dear
friend and um
i did one of his last movies called the
company about um
a ballet company
neff campbell who's in it and
uh
it's a really wonderful film it's a
the quintet not the full orchestra
um
very beautiful film
and of course barbara um i go back to
1970 with him so
we used to party together and that's all
i need say
i
never got out of his company unless the
dawn was breaking
and i think oh why am i doing this but
he was
such a charismatic fun guy to be with
and so i remember this place as one of
the last times i really spent a long
time with him
and i think i've been
films i had here a couple of times
before that i think of one called
gangster number one i'm not sure maybe
i'm getting mixed up with my
film festivals but um
it's uh certainly grown it's um
considered one of the great festivals
and and um it's a real
treat to be here
i
going to what i
almost was my question which is uh what
was it about
uh this story what talk a little bit
about the genesis of the project because
i believe you wrote it because of the
chemistry of your two leads yes um so uh
i had done a film with lily tomlin
called grandma and um
around that time i met jane fonda and um
and the two of them asked me if i would
write something for them and it kind of
stuck in my head and then i had this
idea of
of uh
uh
the opening of a movie of people going
at a funeral there's a widower even this
movie is played by malcolm and people
are saying oh we're so sorry we we loved
you your wife so much we love you etc
and and there's a procession of people
giving condolences and then one woman
who in this movie is jane comes up and
says
i'm gonna kill you this weekend um and
and that's that's the beginning of the
movie and that was the genesis of the
film basically
and um and then it sort of like uh just
subconsciously built itself around that
um i'm not very good at being tactical
about what i should do or shouldn't do
it's really if i if i have ideas that
are building themselves
and then it's it's sort of making things
richer and richer one of the things
about the film that that that resonated
strongly with me is that um
uh it's built on
someone being i don't want to be
specific but it's built on someone being
angry about something that has really
affected their life and they've carried
that anger with them for so many years
uh and even myself i
i relate to that i think we've all at
some point been wronged um and i'm just
so curious for the three of you are you
able to
let go of when someone has wronged you
or you're angry at someone or
are you able to let that go because it's
something that really stuck with me
about the film
in my situation
there is a mixture of
pure unadulterated anger
and
intellectually i would like to let it go
but emotionally it is just it just
it just grinds at you
so when i was claire uh what what what
what happened
i really want to know
what transpired
now don't get me wrong i i've let it all
go i got
married and i have two grandchildren
but
tell me what happened how many wives you
had
how many wives have you had
just two
oh well hey that is not bad
we're talking hollywood here just two
wives jesus i got you beat there buddy
and by the way may i just say that i am
the youngest member of the cast in this
movie
which just shows you
that this is aimed at the young crowd
um well
i
i do think though that when you have a
really fierce emotion and something is
uh when you start to let it out then all
sorts of things can happen and jane
fonda's character in the movie
um
uh
not only it's an interesting tight rope
because she has this thing she's
furious about and wants to get revenge
for and at the same time she's coming in
touch with things in her past that she
loved and and sort of doors for instance
with richard in terms of their
relationship that were closed um and
that that begin to open so uh there's
also a lot of love in the movie which is
nice
i would imagine that making any project
there's a day or two you're always going
to remember um especially for you with
this group of actors and
the people that are not here today um
what's the day or two that you'll always
remember from making this film um just
you know a fun day on set or a
challenging day on set
for me definitely in the gritters park
looking at the carousel that inspired
walt disney to build disneyland or
disney world whatever it was
um i learnt that out later i was quite
taken with that this beautiful old
carousel
and um
it's a very intense scene
and um
full of uh the full gamut of emotions
and um
and the weird thing was it was pages i
can't remember how many
and we got there so early i think i'd
finished it by 11 o'clock in the morning
um i thought we were gonna be here
slugging this out all day
and um and the old paul weiss
by the way
we would have been yeah we've worked
together a number of times malcolm yeah
yeah first in the film inca company i
remember him coming up and saying jesus
christ don't you have it
how many takes do you want on this
[ __ ] speech and by the way the speech
in that when um how long it was a long
one yeah i'd like to challenge you it
was a brilliant piece though but
and i laughed at him and then when he
said that we're doing a tv show um
mozart in the jungle which is
a brilliant tv show
and he said we want you to play you know
the old conductor and i said tv right i
said paul this is tv you know you're not
going to be allowed to do like 20 takes
of he goes no no i know i know i know
don't worry
i got it figured
and he did
mine
was uh
caressing
jane
fonda
wow you and roger vadim
hello hello
i tell you that was uh magical
and i said at one point here i am
wherever we were
caressing jane spanders took us
see you had the nice jane fonda i had
the one that was a total beachy
really well yeah because you know i'm
supposed to have hello well her
character hates malcolm's characters
she's kind of eager to not
hang out with malcolm before because
they hadn't met before and she wanted to
keep in her head the image of certain
roles that malcolm had played as opposed
to the real malcolm
uh so yeah so she said may i please not
meet him before we before we film so i
kind of kept them apart like prize
fighters i um i could ask you guys about
17 other questions but i'm gonna have to
let you go and i'm just going to say i
really sincerely appreciate all three of
you coming in today
to talk about moving on uh i've been a
fan of everyone's work for a very long
time and it really means a lot to me to
have you guys here i'm so happy for you
that it's part of the toronto film
festival and i wish you guys nothing but
the best thank you thank you thanks for
having us